bonsoir pouvoir michel vaujour bonsoir
54 ans dont 27 ans en prison ex-braqueur
à main armée devenue mythique lors de
votre évasion de la prison de la santé
dans un hélicoptère piloté par votre
femme nadine vos jours dont le rôle a
été tenu dans un film par béatrice dalle
se saper la fille de l'air voilà vous
êtes devenu ce jour là pour toujours le
roi de la belle mais aussi l'ennemi
public numéro 1 c'était en 1986 le 26
septembre 1986 exactement
est votre plus belle évasion dites vous
michel vaujour c'est celle où vous êtes
passé par la grande porte de la prison
le 1er septembre 2003 libération
conditionnelle il vous restait 16 ans à
purger voilà alors ma plus belle évasion
c'est le titre du livre que vous publiez
aujourd'hui aux presses de la
renaissance où vous raconter votre vie
alors ce qui est très bizarre avec vous
c'est très jeune déjà quand vous étiez
tout petit
votre père vous disait si tu n'es pas
sage je dirais à vincent ne te mettre en
prison et vincent c'est un pote à votre
père un gros gendarmes rougeau un
journal de campagne comme ça qui devait
vous mettre en prison
ouais j'ai la vie simplement petits
détails ouais ce prémonitoire en même
temps
c'est même du détonateur de battu murray
or vous étiez un enfant compliqué hein
ainsi difficile ou et vous refusiez
l'autorité de votre père vous rejetez
même cette autorité complètement
complètement
vos parents est obligé de vous mettre
chez une chez une tante oui
tout allait très bien ouais
alors à 16 ans vous venez à paris sur
les barricades mai 68 en fait ça vous
plaît pas beaucoup là le côté branlette
intellectuelle de mai 68 ça vaut une
fois qu'ils aient fini le plaisir de des
barricades et puis marc en quoi
c'est un peu vrai remarquer bon l'aide
de cerveau
vous revenez à chalon après 68 fait un
boulot pas très drôle à on faisait quoi
j'ai barre mais les carburateurs c'est
quoi ça avrillé vous avez les plus
drôles que bois et barbes et des
carburateurs à l'air vous enlever ça
sort d'un moule et vous enlever les
arêtes et pasqua ouais enfin bon le
difficile
c'est toujours pareil
alors à 19 ans vous retrouvez à bête que
vous aviez rencontré à paris
c'est votre premier vrai amour vous lui
fait un enfant et là vous commencez à
jouer au papa et à la maman à ce moment
là vous êtes assez rangé des voitures ça
va le problème c'est que vous n'avez pas
de véhicule les distractions sont rares
et la vendredi soir nous emprunté une
voiture et moteur tournant plus c'est
tentant
le carburateur est déjà à bure b tout va
très bien à quoi ils servent à quelque
chose du carburateur
je vais faire une grande balade dans le
vignoble champenois hexabyte dans cette
caisse
non c'est la belle vie
une belle soirée 1 et après vous
recommencez pour conclure paris
10 c'est facile on prend la caisse on va
se balader on la ramène et puis voilà
jusqu'au jour où vous abandonner un
véhicule devant chez vous parce que vous
allez crever oui hélas les flics
débarquent oui
première évasion ça tourne mal vous vous
barré par la fenêtre oui j'ai
jamais une certaine allergie à
l'autorité quoi
je pourrais te barelli si
tu aurais dû me prévenir mon âge ça
puisse arranger quoi alors la bête elle
est arrêtée
vous vous êtes arrêté à votre tour et
quand il est libéré vous attendez qu
elles viennent au parloir elle vient
plus
et vous découvrez qu'elle a refait sa
vie avec le fils d'un policier est-ce
qu'il est très mauvais goût ouais
surtout qu'en plus ça explique la
sanction qui vous frappe
vous en aurez la preuve de ça
rien c'est toujours fait de chez moi
ouais
c'est ça qui vous coupent de la société
ça m'a bien aidé ouais
alors vous êtes libéré vous est interdit
de séjour dans la région de chalon vous
avez travaillé à fos-sur-mer et un jour
vous avez très envie évidemment c'est
normal de revoir zabeth et et votre
enfant vous achetez une ds 19 un copain
le pas de carte grise pas de fermiers
rien du tout vous repartez la retrouver
oui et là vous êtes repéré par les flics
et c'est bizarre d'ailleurs parce qu'au
lieu bon c'est pas dramatique mais
jusqu'où moon pour fuir les flics vous
vous jeter dans la saône sans problème
et si plus si nécessaire je vous fais un
secret de louviers
deuxième séjour en prison ouais première
évasion vous avez des commandes la
première fois michel j'ai pris
c'était une petite prison et même un
camion jo je suis rentré je tiens un
autre retrait pas assez dans la prison
est scellé pour tous ère
est chargé des caisses de de travail qui
a été fait d'un atelier je me suis
arrangée pour aller vite à l'atelier
ensuite
avec une grille a passé je me suis
planqué dans les chiottes à côté de la
grille 1 et dès qu'ils ont là la grille
je suis passé suite fastoche
je me suis fait la peine
le
cclat pour fuir vous déguisé en berger
vous gardé des chèvres un mais c'est des
jeunes et même pas jusqu'au péril
aujourd'hui
la presse à bombay c'est la cavale ces
hold up c'est la prison deuxième évasion
c'est comment la deuxième évasion
un peu plus complexe ouais
et comment
allier un camion là bas ils fermaient
pas
et m'ont mis dans un secteur qui était
un petit peu bloqué un lame de chiba au
escalade ouais
et voilà
c'est qu'avec une évasion devient un jeu
c'est à dire une espèce de challenge
fait pas les la l'autorité vous met dans
des situations un résultat intéressant
alors encore la cavale encore la prison
et là il ya une évasion absolument
extraordinaire c'est que vous arrivez à
prendre l'empreinte des clés des
gardiens avec de la cire rouge tu sais
qu'ils emballent les baby beel
facile à et nous fournissez le baby beel
ainsi babybel merci
alors là quand même
là quand même si tu veux là quand même
quand vous êtes rattrapez vous mettre en
qhs leurs quartiers d'été
ouais alors il connaît les avantages de
la carte évasion
pas encore
en tous les cas quand vous êtes au hawk
uh s vous prenez conscience du gâchis
qu'est votre vie et il n'y a qu'une
chose qui peut vous motiver c'est l'idée
de vous évader quoi ce moment là c'est
la seule chose quoi et les chaussures
j'ai 25 ans je vous tourner prison à
faire
partir d'une connerie mouais c'est lourd
et la nuit devant 26 ans vous vous
organiser pour vous même une étrange
cérémonie vous entrez dans une espèce
d'ascèse vous raser la tête vous jetez
le tabac qui vous restent dans les
toilettes vous casser votre radio vous
êtes nu vous êtes à genoux et vous créer
une espèce de prison à l'intérieur de la
prison c'est à dire que vous vous rendez
encore plus dur que ce qu'on voudrait
que vous soyez final c'est dur à 16 dans
une cellule
flash va rayer
merci michel tu es un bon gars
oui pourquoi vous faites ça c'est à dire
que vous dites il faut que jamais il
faut que je me durcissent encore plus
quoi la seule façon qu'on puisse ne pas
être atteint un sondé tout à soi même je
pense qu'on peut plus rien vous enlevez
ouais ouais quand on peut plus rien vous
enlevez ont paré à vous faire les gens
accès si vous
écrivez
et là vous évader alors du palais de
justice avec un pistolet en savant
extraordinaire non parce qu'il est
marrant parce que c'est vraiment des
trucs de ses bibis
philippe lhez quoi hein malheureusement
il pleut et là
c'était presque sera la fin ça ça sur
internet est temps que ça se termine mal
il avait un pistolet en savon et du
cirage et pour faire le clip parce que
ce qui était important quand on
complètement de braque un flingue sait
qui est le bruit de l'armement le
cliquetis et ça vous avez un coupe ongle
pour le faire bien sûr modifiée avec une
petite caisse de résonance à partir
d'une boîte de sardines 1
mais dans le silence de la confrontation
entre les poulets et moi quoi quand on
se regardent dans le blanc des yeux ça
fait du bruit quand on fait
là vous rentrez dans le grand banditisme
vous retrouvez votre pote gilles vous
devenez l'amant de sa soeur qui est
divorcée nadine qui deviendra un nadine
vos jours et là vous accumulez l'argent
ces braquages c'est une espèce de vie de
western comme ça pour finir en amérique
du sud mais gilles et arrêter là c'est
très serré près c'est comme un film ça
veut dire qu'au moment où vous commencez
à avoir suffisamment d'argent pour
partir en amérique du sud quand gilles
et arrêtez vous décidé de rester deux ou
trois ans de plus finalement pour
attendre quoi
c'est fou
c'est comme ça pour moi l'amitié c'était
ça ouais et michel les braquages
gentleman ou un peu violent comme t'es
jamais toujours obtient deux semaines
un moment tôt ou tard et ça s'est
présenté bien plus tard un traumatisme
pour les gens quand tu rentres a été un
flop quand même j'ai toujours essayé de
faire en douceur mais vous en faites
plus nos pommes savidan c'est encore ça
marche bien c'est les braquages moderne
est-ce que c'était pas vrai l'histoire
du 150 millions là c'est une blague
alors voilà donc gilles et arrêtez vous
ne partez pas en amérique du sud vous
passé deux ans à attendre et en italie
ça se passe plutôt bien inviter à l'igs
est heureux nickel nicaise mais à un
moment les flics italien cherche les
brigades rouges et vous vous dites ça
ils vont commencer à m'emmerder
voilà j'avais un problème avec ça une
nouvelle loi qui sont passés il partait
dans la drôme la sq a un truc terrible
vous fait refaire le visage
donc vous dites là je suis trop bouger
très parano dit ni complètement c'est le
propre de la chirurgie
et vous êtes trahi par vos empreintes
vous retrouvez à la prison de la santé
gillet tuer et c'est nadine et sa femme
qui vient de chercher en élite et
lui a des grosses chaussettes rouges 1
pourquoi on vous voit c'est bien ça elle
vous voient comme ça elle s'approche
vous avez ou pendant la grippe en
sérieux rappi l'automne et l'école était
courageuse
[Musique]
on l'a fait une première fois gilles a
été tué ensuite
le brevet a été découvert par l'art par
les mailles de nos services la pression
du prosélytisme
alors passer une deuxième fois sous un
autre nom
accumuler les heures de vol surtout aux
stationnaire à la précision quoi
et après c'est après c'est une opération
une mise au point
c'est tout quand vous allez en prison
comment est ce que vous arrivez à
communiquer avec nadine pour savoir
qu'il faut mettre les grandes
chaussettes rouges et tout ça
m'a quand même
mais bon
ouais
d'accord alors là vous faites des
braquages et vous prenez une balle dans
la tête à ça fait pas mal sur les nazis
il lui a toujours la balle à j'ai un
côté comme ça je arthur touche sa tempe
droite tu va la sentir et quand il passe
à l'aéroport
vous avez une balle quelque part je
prends pas l'avion où ça soit adapté
n'ai pas peur à tombe pas un mauvais
souvenir
assez impressionnant
ça va
mais moi ça m'a touché je vais te
montrer un truc
annonçant l'abandon
il a gardé il a aidé à garder la balle
dans la tête toujours du bonheur
non il peut pas longer et une lèvre il
ya plutôt les coques ces
espèces il a un tatouage aussi sur
l'épaule gauche
ouais ça m'impressionne mois là ça tu
vois quand tu connaîtras le texte à
estelle pour la vie
non c'est pas ça c'est un loup hurle à
l'amour complètement placebo et aulas
est mort l'autre et au foyer vous avez
les trois points
ces trois points vont les voilà qu'ils
ont vu en tournée pour voler alors vous
restez unis fléchi qu'après cette balle
vrai dans le cerveau hélas le yoga vous
aident énormément pour wii comment vous
êtes arrivé accès très importante ça
pour les gens qui nous regardent comment
les canaris la combattre l'ennemi fléchi
et à s'en sortir parce que vous en êtes
sortis avec le mental babybel maintenant
bien
à mise à mort bischheim bizarrement
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on en croit ces
techniques aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
passe et technique j'ai entendu ça il ya
deux ou trois ans mais à l'époque ça
s'employer pas quoi ces voyages
intérieurs
encore la recherche d'une sensation
puisque l'hémiplégie c'est
justement la perdre les sensations n'y a
plus aucune sensation et a
même l'effacement du schéma mental de
cette partie du corps
s'il reste une petite sensation
mais l'acte iv d'activer l'activé
l'activer
vous avez récupéré quoi 90% là j'avais
récupéré presque à 100% tu as perdu à
force de tout simplement m'asseoir
devant l'ordinateur et travailler pour
m'en sortir a su rester assis pendant
quatre ans au moins que ce à quoi alors
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que
c'est toujours les femmes vous qui vous
qui vous sortent de là est une a dit n'y
en a eu d'autres mais celle qui vous
sauvera ses jamila ans d'abord à l'essai
avec un hélico elle aussi mais c'est
raté quoi c'est raté la deuxième fois ça
marche moins bien mais en tous les cas
c'est son amour qui va vraiment vous
sauver c'est ce que vous appelez ma plus
belle évasion complètement fait
la seule chose qu'il faut se battre quoi
c'est ça
c'est tout vous avez décidé à un moment
vous dites voilà je me marie avec jamila
quand vous marier avec elle elle doit
vous attendre pendant 21 ans débat
avec aucune chance de sortie j'étais
moins considérées comme totalement
irrécupérable
aucune perspective c'est un engagement
quant à un engagement qui dépasse est-ce
que vous pouvez comprendre vraiment quoi
non bien sûr non mais oui d'être à être
dire à quelqu'un je vois dans 21
et j'ai ouvert l'époque cette fuite
aujourd'hui chi public que jamais
indépendamment même de ma liberté
physique
et ça c'est le titre du livre
[Musique]
michel jeu on m'a plu l'invasion
m
pensez quoi michel de la libération de
lucien léger la vidéo ne peut pas être
réduit à 40 ans de prison est enfermé
dans la tôle allait devenir un légume on
une balle dans la tête c'est clair c'est
net ces progrès au jeu ça c'est solide
et ça c'est si vous pensez que la soul
vite lassé que la vraie perpétuité
finalement c'est comme la peine de mort
quoi et puis il faut être sérieux
non on a l'impression d'avoir les mains
propres c'est tout on a l'impression de
fieux enfin et civilisé si tout va bien
vous en pensez-quoi jack la libération
de lucien léger après 41 ans de prison
je pense qu'en effet la perpétuité
parfois c c'est une sorte peine de mort
propre inscrits
camouflet se débarrasse d'un être vivant
est heureux on le fait mourir tous les
jours en cage je n'oublie pas
naturellement le crime abominable dont
il a été l'auteur assassinat d'un enfant
c'est là peut-être la pire des choses
qu'on puisse imaginer qu'ils qui
aujourd'hui encore pour ceux qui ont
connu cette époque touche beaucoup
profondément mes 40 ans de taule il ya
un petit progrès je dirais qui a été
accompli par la législation c'est que
dans temps c'était le gouvernement qui
décide et la libération mortels
maintenant j'essaie cjs astrov parce que
le gouvernement dans ce domaine manque
de courage ou bien et on a confié sa à
une jury à une commission
l'émission silence et vous
csc dont monsieur lang évoque c'est que
monsieur là c'est exactement ce qui m'a
permis de changer il n'y aurait pas eu
ça
ya pas de perspective quand ya pas de
perspective qu'est-ce qu'on fait
impression qu on attend c'est pas le
style
voilà on s'évade si je vois là tu peux
permet d'ajouter une chose quand même et
aujourd'hui des gens qui sont très vieux
très malade pour pouvoir rien à mon nom
pour voir peut-être en taule en taule
on a trouvé le moyen de libérer qui vous
savez très aisément aisément papon papa
ben partir rapon comment ça se fait
qu'il est libre certainement il est
sorti dans le mec est sorti de la santé
au courant at en eau et aujourd'hui il
ya des dizaines de personnes âgées quoi
faire qui sont là depuis des années des
années vieux très malin très très malade
est anormal qu'on les maintiennent en
taule d'enfants square sur le tout ça
toi
je suis assez fasciné par j'ai pas lu le
livre je suis assez fasciné parce qu'on
est tous fascinés par c'est pas
péjoratif mais pas assez vite de
gangsters quoi bon si c'est pas
péjoratif un animateur non plus c'est
toujours ce nom mais quel métier 1
ça fait
evadez-vous là allez-y c'est la dernière
michel vaujour
région c'est aux fraises de la rooney
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus